now to the legacy of congressman john
lewis who fought his entire life to help
america live up to its
ideals of freedom justice and equality
his work began with demonstrations and
demands
and continued for decades in washington
where he became known
as a conscience of congress congressman
lewis
never stopped being an activist cbs this
morning saturday co-host
michelle miller has more on what it took
lewis to bring us all closer to a just
society
michelle i know you've known him a very
long time good morning to you
good morning well john lewis the
congressman was
instrumental in shaping this nation's
freedoms one of his greatest
achievements
was the national museum of
african-american history
and culture something he fought for for
15 years he called it
a dream come true he was a living
blueprint for change
through non-violence and then he said an
effective leader
because he lived it so it doesn't matter
whether we are black
or white latinos asian american or
native american
whether we are gay or straight we are
one family
john lewis not only had a way with words
get out there
and push and pull until we redeem the
soul of america
but was revered for the change his words
inspired
for someone to grow up the way i grew up
in the cotton fields of alabama
the civil rights titan often discussed
his own family's story
rising from the ashes sometimes i feel
like crying
tears of happiness tears of joy the city
distance we've come
as a reminder of how far this nation has
come
and the progress that can still be made
when people tell me nothing has changed
i just feel like saying come and walk in
my shoes i will show you
lewis was after all a man who walked the
walk
we do not want our freedom gradually but
we want to be free now
fighting against injustice and for
racial equality almost his entire life i
kept saying to myself
how many more young
black men will be murdered and it's my
hope
that we are on our way to greater change
lewis
embodied non-violence it was a
cornerstone in his philosophy
when you see something that is not right
not fair
not just something he was arrested at
least
45 times for peacefully protesting
good trouble he called it you only pass
this way once
you have to give it all you have and he
gave all he had
in 1965 lewis led an historic march from
selma to montgomery alabama
which sparked the passage of the voting
rights act the brutal crackdown of the
protest at edmund pettus bridge
known as bloody sunday was a turning
point for lewis
and the nation he went on to serve as a
congressman representing georgia for
over 30 years
and became known as the conscience of
the congress
in 2011 he was awarded the presidential
medal of freedom
race courage and commitment to justice
president obama
saying this moment preserve protect and
defend
the constitution of the united states so
help you god so help me god
congratulations was only possible
because of the sacrifices lewis made
in the end lewis said that as long as he
has breath in his body
he would do what he can and he did he
fought with humility
and above all he fought with love
and congressman lewis lived by the
message that
love will always conquer hate and he
always seemed to rise above
violence that was an ideology he shared
with ct vivian another civil rights
organizer
who worked closely with martin luther
king jr and
crossed paths with lewis in a twist of
fate
vivian passed away the very same day as
lewis
due to natural causes he was 95
years old tony yeah two big losses there
you say he was a lover in addition to
being a fighter and he believed that
love would triumph over hate he was an
optimist as well we should remember that
he wouldn't have begun the fight in the
first place if he were not
we should continue that fight as well
michelle thank you very much